-Oh, my gosh. I'm so happy.
Pump the crowd noise in now.
-Yeah, exactly.
-I'm so happy that you're
on the show.
I got to tell you, I'm a fan.
I was screaming at the TV,
so proud of you and proud
of our country,
and I was seriously,
like, tears.
It was like watching one of
those awesome sports movies,
except it was real life.
I could just imagine
what it was like for you.
-Yeah, I mean, honestly,
I feel like it was
a little bit the same for me
as it is for you,
but, like, I have to keep it
together a little bit
because I'm like,
"We're supposed to be here."
And like, "We're doing the
winning thing, but like --"
-Yeah.
-It's like a childhood dream
come true,
but then it actually comes true,
and then you're like,
"Wait, what do I do now?
No one ever talked about
the what do you do
when you do it part."
So then I just had as much fun
as possible, basically.
-Oh, man, the world was watching
you, man, and rooting for you.
Right now, you actually would
have been in Tokyo, correct?
You would have been
at the Olympics.
-Yeah, mm-hmm.
Yeah.
-Bizarre times we live in.
Are you prepping
for the Olympics
for next year or not yet?
-I mean...
-Too soon?
-Kind of.
Yeah, it's a little too soon.
It's a really weird,
like, training
sort of spot that we're in.
It's like you can't really
go hard and stay
at, like, your highest level,
because you can't do that
all year round, and so --
-Yeah.
-It's actually really bizarre.
We're used to having everything
planned out in our lives
pretty much for years at a time.
And so when the pandemic hit,
it was kind of like,
well, are we just --
we're working out for health
I guess. Got a Peloton,
doing yoga, doing Pilates.
I'm just trying
to, like, stay healthy.
And, you know, do all --
-Put on the Lululemons
and go for it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you have to.
-Yeah.
-You're also known for activism
as well,
which I really love about you.
You're the first non-NFL athlete
to take a knee,
and you got a lot of heat
for that one.
And now I see a lot of sports
are supporting taking a knee.
I know Major League Baseball
did it, WNBA did it.
I think the NBA has a thing.
But what was the shift
there you think?
-I think the pandemic,
honestly, sort of laid bare
a lot of the lies
that were told.
We don't, oh, it's going to be
too much for healthcare,
and too much --
well, we found like $3 trillion,
like really easily.
I was like, "Did we just have
this the whole time?
Like, we just had
to, like, vote on it?"
So I think people are kind of
starting to connect
all of the different dots.
I think we've seen
what's happened to Colin
over all of these years
and how much backlash he's got,
but then all of these things
come into fruition,
literally what he's talking
about being played out,
you know, for all of us
to see in these videos.
I guess my hope is that people
are starting to connect the dots
and realizing that we don't have
to live in a world like this.
We don't have to live in a world
where, you know,
we don't have healthcare
that's adequate
and our schools
aren't adequate.
We're one of the richest
countries in the world.
Like, we can do better
for ourselves.
And we can do better for the
people that are living here.
-Is that what you're going
to talk about when --
You're now a talk show host.
You should have called me
for advice.
Now we're now in the same club.
This Saturday at 10:00 p.m.
on HBO.
What do you talk
about on your show?
What is it about?
-It's called "Seeing America."
I'm sort of on this mission
to, like, make politics cool.
And I feel like politics
is always this thing,
and it's sort of meant
to be like this
or it's packaged as, "Oh,
this is not this cool thing.
It's difficult to get
involved in,
just, like, kind of stay
out of it."
And then people are like,
"Well, I don't really
want to get involved."
And it's like, actually,
politics is engaging with you
whether you're engaging
with it or not,
all the time no matter what.
Your whole life is political,
especially if you're
a black person,
or a black trans woman
or a gay woman like myself
or a gay female athlete.
You know, our lives
are political in so many ways.
And so, trying to break it down
for people,
to make it a little
bit more relatable
and then get people energized
about getting involved
in the civic process
and getting involved,
and, you know -- just being more
active in their communities,
but also for themselves
as well.
Obviously, voting is a huge one.
We're coming up on
the general election,
which is, you know,
I mean,
definitely in my lifetime
the most important one,
but certainly a hugely
consequential election.
-Yeah, 2016, I think, 'cause
I was looking at the website,
When We All Vote, and it said,
100 million people didn't vote.
-100 million people didn't vote.
-Did not vote,
so let's change that.
It's free. You just
have to register
and you have your voice heard.
Why not do that?
-Yeah.
I mean, When We All Vote
is amazing.
It's bipartisan, and voting
in general should be bipartisan.
We should try to be getting
as many people involved
in voting as possible.
You know, it's one
of the greatest things
about our country.
We live in a democratic country,
and so everyone can participate
and have their voice heard.
You know, this is coming
from me,
but there's a reason why certain
people or certain parties work
so hard
to keep people out of voting.
I think that the more
people vote,
the more the policies
of the country
reflect the people
that are voting
and ultimately take care of
the people that are voting from,
all the way from the presidency
down-ballot.
In this pandemic in general
we're seeing
how important mayors are
and how important
the governors are.
-Yeah.
-You know, it's like
Gavin Newsom and,
you know, the governor
from New York, Cuomo,
they've become, like,
these superstars in this way,
but it's like,
they're really important.
They have a huge job.
And so all of these things
affect our daily lives
every day.
And so to get as many
people registered
so their voice can be heard,
so the policies can reflect
their needs and the needs
of their communities, I think,
is the most important thing
that we can do right now.
-Megan, before we leave,
do you want to move your scarf
out of the way?
I don't know if it was
covering your shirt,
but I just thought it was pretty
important that you see it.
-Yes.
-Thank you so much
for coming on my show.
I'm a big fan.
Please come back, and I'd love
to see you in person.
-Yeah, let's do this
in person again,
and it's a great time
to arrest the cops,
so, say her name,
Breonna Taylor,
rest in peace,
you went too soon.
-Megan Rapinoe, everybody.
Check out whenweallvote.org
for more information
on how to get involved.
We'll be right back with
a performance from Angel Olsen.
Stick around.